let's talk about chart formatting so
let's look at this example of a chart
and now I want to improve this chart
together with you and so here for this
chart I would recommend you to rather
use tone down colors very basic colors
because I argue all these colors here
don't really help you to bring across
any message the next thing that might
come to mind is all these lines that you
see here it just looks very crowded very
busy so probably the first thing I want
to take out are these connector lines
between the bars and the same thing is
likely also true for all these helper
lines all these grid lines in the
background and yeah I'd argue what I
take out is also the y-axis to the side
in this example you already have all the
numbers on top of the bars why you need
to show this additional axis take it out
and you will be very fine and now what I
would encourage you to add maybe you
want to show how the revenues increased
and if this is indeed the case why don't
include a different arrow that shows how
the revenue increased by 400 percent
from 2015 to 2021